welcome to this video playing lunatic ex
let's see what we got here from Czech
Republic going for the Sicilian sea half
a name here padam chalak okay going for
the Kalashnikov don't know that very
well but let's let's see try to get them
playable sicilian position without any
huge theoretical workload chang not sure
that this was also great but yeah
because of that but okay it's still a
very very solid position for black
nothing that worries me too much night
to be six maybe and Bishop c4 sis's idea
maybe
hmm interesting 94 is this sir txtx
trying to play against the night ii m
okay let's let's castle first and then
reconsider again 94s may be possible
takes takes Queen takes Bishop of sixes
very likely okay for me maybe Queen B
form
cannot play Bishop g5 which I would like
to do takes takes pawn takes hmm should
a six queen bee farm I still feel that
this is the right move somehow it takes
it twice Knight to c4 I have be five
okay let's let's do this based on the
fact that i have this tempo and now i
thought a 5 because there's also be two
attacked maybe you can just play Queen B
5 but then this Bishop deform for more
activity
okay should be fun yeah it's not
brilliant right but ok it's nothing else
really that I am that I have him now I
can take and try to play I can take and
play Queen f6 actually so that I take b2
+ f2 or queen f6 immediately is this any
better I don't know but I think I have
decent chances to get a good
compensation here or get the pong back
at least and then maybe I lose a 5 but i
have from some things going in my favor
here mostly the very good bishop okay
i'm going here and then put the bishop
on c5 here Oh is there some some better
some better idea I can I need to I need
to go there in any case so might as well
do this right now that's 45 I see wants
to play rook f3 understand yeah okay
something I should have tried to prevent
ok let's try to get the Queen's of at
least yeah
this is here rupee 8g 16g 7 is my plan
to finally at the end try to get get
this pressure get rid of this pressure
on the on f7 yeah I'm a pawn down but
the real question is the the question of
activity if I manage to let's say get
rid of this pressure on f7 and trade
trade trade rooks then I don't have any
problems whatsoever rookie 5 + f5 is a
is a suitable way to try to accomplish
that yeah I can take f2 now if I want
getting to a look endgame I think I can
play G form only I've FB should be three
check so I can actually take it should
be successful f it should be three okay
time morning it should be three check
and we have in that position now there
are our third so you playing this on
really what the poor person
brah our third yeah if you have too much
time on your hands you can play a
position like that unfortunately it's
hit so drawers that I have absolutely
hindle no idea here to punish him for
that simply so dead that I can do I can
do nothing now I know I win a pony even
bra our third game draw okay so I I
think that I should have been in trouble
somehow but it didn't really materialize
maybe this way of gaining counterplay
was okay I wasn't sure really a five I
computer really likes black so did I
overlooked something promising here
green edge for is an interesting move
how could I miss my favorite move Queen
H form yeah it's really interesting
attacking here and after casa lets you
take the pawn so black gets the porn bag
and he has this active position ya
understand here really only black can be
better the computer gives black half a
porn so pretty much what you can expect
for a bishop pair position no I didn't
consider that Elvis I was beforehand I
was planning this and I thought that
this type of
should give me a decent chances to to
have activity for for my for my porn so
if you look at the position I'm let's
say I'm lacking the a porn here and this
is not very important I have a good
position with this bishop what really is
a problem is this potential pressure on
f7 but I'm not sure that he really
should trade queens here maybe you
should try to keep the Queen's on I mean
here is this really so so bad for me Jim
maybe there is some way for him to to
put more pressure on me but I wasn't
really seeing anything I think once we
got to this point I'm pretty much okay
even if the computer loves right but the
drawing tendencies of the opposite
colored bishops are clearly there and
here I thought you would play f4 here
the sir is still a substantial try but
he blundered the f2 upon a forest says
is of course something that why
definitely can try it's it has enormous
enormous drawing tendencies but it this
is something that white can definitely
play on with justification after this
it's it's just check just totally dead
okay thanks for watching